we are ready to go we'll begin with this
there was growing uncertainty this
morning for immigrant families who's
sick children are being treated in the
u.s. it comes after the Trump
administration rolled back a program
allowing families to live in the US
while receiving medical care
Errol Barnett is in Boston where he
spoke to an immigrant family whose Ilsan
is being treated there so Errol what do
they have to say well Gail the family
which is from Honduras and here in the
US legally said that this policy
rollback may cost a sixteen-year-old son
his life the Sanchez has already lost
their daughter to cystic fibrosis but
really found a sense of hope for their
son here at Boston Children's now though
that sense of hope is turning into dread
this is reality for Jonathan Sanchez
three times a day the 16 year old is
hooked up to machines to treat his
cystic fibrosis
now his life-saving treatment and care
may be coming to an end how do you feel
when you when you don't get the
treatment I started the cuff a lot of
rolling off hard time to breathing and I
get chest pain Jonathan's family says
they came to the u.s. from Honduras in
2016 on tourist visas for his treatment
they recently applied to stay under the
Medical deferred action program but
earlier this month the policy was
quietly rolled back effectively ending
all pending or future requests and
program renewals in this moment I don't
know where we humpin in the future last
week parents in Boston including
Jonathan's say they received this notice
from US Citizenship and Immigration
Services ordering them to leave the
country within 33 days or face
deportation in my perspective it's
making legal homicide why do you say
that because in Central America there's
no treatment no medicines no doctors no
specialists nothing Gary Sanchez is
Jonathan's father all his life I try to
be a good father because he came to ADP
you think the only thing that will
happen
- Jonathan if he goes back to Honduras
as though he will die we don't know how
much time but you know short time she
will be back come to us at the end of
our interview Jonathan's mother Mariela
could not hold back her tears they Macon
Parker Johnson is the family's
immigration attorney how many families
do you think this impacts we think it's
probably in the hundreds across the
nation for Jonathan and his family all
they can ask for now is help sending
back all of those children's who needed
the treatment clothing myself they're
just murdering us they're killing us the
deportation in other words means death
now Citizenship and Immigration Services
confirmed to CBS News that it is ending
this program although in their words
they say they're just changing the
approval process and deferring to ice on
this but an ice official tells CBS News
it was not consulted at all about this
policy change and Adriana only found out
about it after all those letters were
sent out to families across the country
Wow Errol thank you that program gets
about a thousand applicants a year so
we're talking about a lot of people
affected seems like there to figure out
a way to work something out when you
hear a story like that let's hope so
yeah